let's learn how to solve the Rubik's
Cube naturally if you have a Rubik's
Cube handy you'll want to go get it and
be prepared to use the pause button a
lot we solve the cube in eight steps
first we have the the daisy then the
easy and the one two three move those
three moves are going to give us are
going to solve for us the the bottom
layer of the cube then we'll do the step
four we'll do the middle layer that's
the belt that goes around the middle of
the cube and then with steps five six
seven and eight with such fun names as
fur Earth the fun move the r Prime f
move and the furl move will have the
entire uh top layer solved
all right here are the ground rules for
most Rubik's Cubes the white face and
the yellow face are on opposite sides
white face yellow face we will solve the
entire cube with the white face on the
bottom and the and the yellow face on
the top okay so if your Cube has
something other than yellow opposite the
white face then that color's face will
always be on the top we are now ready
for step one the daisy now as always we
keep the yellow face on the top our goal
is to give this yellow Center four white
petals that is the four white Edge
pieces so it looks like a daisy the
first place I look for my white edges is
on the middle layer okay now let's see
when I see here oh I've got a white one
right here I just bring that to my top
that's my first Daisy petal this could
be my second Daisy petal but you know
what that's too easy I want to teach you
something let's let's look on the bottom
for for one here
oh okay so so here here's a daisy petal
I'm going to first bring it to the I'm
going to first bring it to the middle
layer
like so so now it's on the middle layer
and once something's on the middle layer
you can turn it up
and there it is let's look for another
one anything on the middle layer oh I've
got one on the middle layer right here
now I would turn that one right up
but I'd lose this white daisy piece so
let's move that Daisy petal out of the
way so that now when we move it up
there it is and one more anything on the
bottom layer no let's see so it must be
oh look at that there's one right here
at the very bottom let me move it in
position let's let's get those other
daisies petals out of the way rotate
that 180 degrees and we're done
now pause and practice this step many
times until you're comfortable that you
can get all four white Edge pieces to
the top layer the next step is actually
easier
okay after the daisy step step two is so
easy I call it the easy now every petal
of your Daisy is an edge piece with two
colors right here I have white and
orange white and blue white and red
white and green what we now do is we
twist our Cube we're always keeping the
yellow on the top we twist our cube in
such a way that the like the green here
Finds Its Center so watch I'll twist
and Outlook the green has found its
Center okay once it Finds Its Center we
twist that entire face
180 degrees so right now it's pointing
at 12 o'clock
after I after I twist it 180 degrees
it's pointing to six o'clock here let's
do another phase Oh look The Orange is
already found its Center so let's twist
that let's I call this dialing down
let's dial down
okay now we're here how about this one
oh well okay if if um I have the blue
and the red already lined up but if they
weren't lined up if they were in this
situation I would just go hunting around
until
I found the center
twist it dial it down just like that
doesn't matter whether you do this
clockwise or counterclockwise
and finally with the white red piece
notice the reds are matching if they
weren't you'd you would adjust it so
that they were and dial it down
and now once you've done that take a
look what you have on the bottom you
have a white cross
not only do you have a white cross every
piece is where it's supposed to be right
we have the we have the the blue the
white blue where it should be the white
red where it should be the white green
and the white orange you can almost
think of it as the the cube is wearing
socks okay so when you look around it
you see that it's wearing socks
okay we're halfway done with the bottom
layer the white Edge pieces are in place
now it's time to get the White Corners
in their proper positions all right
let's first find a white corner piece
now the best place to look for them is
on the top Rim okay not the top face not
so interested in the white one over here
but on the top Rim like one over here
okay we just have this one over here
okay
so
um now twist the top face notice that
every corner piece
has another color in this case orange
that's also on the top Rim okay so you
see we have a white orange piece here
we're going to twist the top so that the
orange color Finds Its Center so let's
say I have white orange here if I twist
the top just like so
then
then the orange has found its Center and
the white square attached to it will
still be on the rim either on the left
side or on the right side so go ahead
and point to the white square with your
index finger okay like like here there's
my white white square
and I'm going to mark it with one of
these
stickers
so we can see it later
okay A little happy face okay so
um now if you're pointing with your left
hand then the next move will use your
left hand if you were pointing with your
right hand the next move will use the
right hand all right so the next the
move that we're going to learn I call it
the one two three move
now with the pointing hand in this case
in my case it's my left hand I'm going
to twist the side of that Cube away from
you away from me all right so here the
first uh first I go one
like that
now two with your index finger twist the
top face towards you I'm twisting the
top face towards me notice I notice that
I'm now staring at that old white
sticker it is staring me in the face or
I'm staring at its face and finally
that's step two and finally step three I
bring that white square down by twisting
the side of the cube towards me like
that
and now that white Corner cube is in its
proper position not only do I have a
white there you'll notice that we have
green matching green and the orange
matching the orange
was that too fast for you that's okay
we've got three more corners to go again
if we're lucky we'll find we'll find
another white corner on the rim oh I've
got a couple of these here on the rim
okay let's see so
uh let's let's see I've got a white red
here let's twist the top until the red
Finds Its Center
just like that red red diagonally
touching and the white piece is on the
side okay here let's let's do a
another uh sticker so you can watch what
happens to that white piece
okay we're going to do the one two three
move again so now this time I'm pointing
with my right finger so I'm going to use
my right hand so one I twist it away
from me
then two I twist it towards me you see
I'm staring at that face again all right
and then three we're going to bring that
down
all right we bring it down and now that
face is in its proper position you can
tell it's very happy
okay let's do it again two more corners
I look around the rim oh there's a rim
right white and blue
um I'll let the I wanted to find its
Center so let's twist it so that the
blue matches its Center the white is on
the side the white will always be on the
side either with on your right side or
on your left side you'll you don't want
to have a white facing you here you're
not going to want to have a white that
you that white in the back you want it
on the right side or left side here it's
on my right side again so with my right
hand I do one
two there's that white sticker and and
down like this three
all right let's look around look around
okay I've got one more to go it's white
and blue oh look it's already in its
right position all right and now I get
to use my left hand in order to put that
in the proper position so here we go
with the left hand we do one away from
me two I twist the top towards me
three
down
and now the bottom layer is solved
now that was easy maybe it was too easy
because there was a complication we
didn't actually uh experience so let me
set that up for you
Suppose there aren't any white pieces on
the top rim
but you do have a white piece on the top
on the top face like here okay so
nothing on the rim so in that situation
all you do is you twist the top you want
to get that white white piece above
one of the unsolved positions doesn't
matter which one it is just just
um it can't be over something that's
already been solved so find something
that isn't white preferably so here's
the white is now directly above the
orange okay and now with the my right
hand because it's on my right side I'm
going to do the one not not the one two
three move but the one two two three
move all right when I go one two two
three watch we go uh we go one
2 2
3. now it didn't solve the bottom but
that white piece is now on the rim a
mathematician would say we've reduced
this to a problem that we know how to
solve okay so here let's now fix it
by letting the the white has a blue
neighbor the blue Finds Its Center
and let's see uh so it's it's here the
white is on the right so with my right
hand I'll do one two three and that
gives me
the completely solved bottom
there's only one other situation to to
be aware of if you don't have any whites
on the top rim or even on the top face
then all you do is you find let's say
you had a white that was in position
here do a one two three move and that
will bring that offending white piece to
the top rim and once it's on the top you
know how to solve that position
okay it's essential that you practice
step three and steps one and two for
that matter until you can confidently
solve the bottom layer and I encourage
you to do so now
if you get stuck don't be afraid to
rewind me and I'm happy to explain it to
you again
okay you now know how to solve the
bottom layer and from now on every time
we finish a step the bottom layer will
still be in its pristine state
let me show you one of those steps right
now we won't really need it until step
six but it's so easy to learn and so fun
to do that I call it the fun move while
I teach you the move I will also display
some notation along the way I won't
really explain the notation now but I
want you to start seeing it now so it'll
make more sense when we need it in step
five
it's done entirely with the right hand
and all you do is Twist the right face
that would be
um by the way I'm making sure my yellow
is still on top here okay so all you do
is you twist the right face
and the top face
okay as follows now watch and listen
closely
okay I'm twisting the right face and the
top face we sometimes call the top face
the up face as well but okay here we go
we twist out
twist in twist out twist twist in
okay here you try it all right you go
out twist in twist out twist twist in
notice that after the move the bottom
layer is still pristine no matter how
you've oriented it out twist in twist
out twist twist in
all right this time I'll do it with
numbers these are the numbers that we
used in the one two three move it goes
one two
three two one two two three
one last time this time I'll have the
notation displayed remember we're
twisting the right face and the up face
it goes out twist in twist out twist
twist in
isn't it fun okay now practice this a
few times and eventually you'll learn it
you'll learn it kinesthetically your
hands will just learn it so you don't
even have to pay much attention while
you do it okay once you've got that down
it's time for step four all right I'm
gonna peel off the the happy face uh
stickers right now so since we won't
need those till later by the way I've
known some people who solve the Rubik's
Cube by peeling off the stickers of
their Cube and rearranging those I just
have to warn you if you do that you know
if you find that step three wasn't
working for you it's possible one of
your kids has already peeled off some
stickers and put them in the wrong
places and that could that could create
problems okay now we've completed the
bottom layer all right completely done
it's now time for the middle layer uh
now there are no corners in this middle
layer right it's just the belt that goes
around it so we just have to do four
Edge pieces we do these one at a time we
begin by looking at the top layer for
any Edge piece that doesn't use the
color yellow say I've got a green and
orange I got a red and green I and I've
got two two things that have yellows on
it I like red and green let's do that
okay so I've got a red green Edge piece
the first thing you do is you twist the
cube until the the color on the rim that
would be the Green Piece Finds Its color
okay so
um Finds Its Center so here it is we
find its Center and now on the top
there's red what do I do with red Now
red will either be on this side or that
side is it here no it must be there so
with that with that I'll point to the to
the red side in fact I'm going to give
it a slap mentally or physically slap
the left side
and now your first step is you twist the
top in the direction of the slab so if I
go like here I'm going to with my index
finger I'm going to twist the top
towards me
okay and now what you do is with that
same slapping hand you perform the one
two three move from last step we go one
two three
now uh oh we lost a white from the
bottom right but that's not a problem
the white is back here on the rim so
we're going to fix it we'll fix it by
the white has a red neighbor the red
Finds Its Center and we fix it with the
one two three move one two three and
notice not only is the Bottom now fixed
but that red green Edge piece that we
started with is now in its perfect
position
all right if if you didn't catch it
that's okay we got three more Edge
pieces to do it so you so here's another
um okay here's another one with green
and orange now I got lucky the green had
already found its Center if it wasn't if
it was here I would have Twisted it so
that the green Finds Its Center its
neighbor on top is orange orange is on
the right side I'll slap it with my
right hand and in the direction of the
slap I'll twist the top just like that
now I do the one two three move with my
slapping hand with my right hand here we
go
one two three uh oh we lost a white but
that's okay we'll we'll fix it using the
one two three move with my left hand
it's always with the opposite hand that
will fix it for you one two three and
now that piece the orange green piece is
where it belongs let's look again for
okay here we have a blue orange piece
right here right blue orange piece
actually you know what let me just show
you an example because what would happen
if if all the pieces had yellow on them
and we still weren't weren't done like
let's say we found ourselves here with a
a blue red piece you know and everything
up on top and yellow but these weren't
in the right position then all you do is
you do a one two three move no slapping
required just do a one two three move
one two three and then that and then fix
it say okay well I'll fix that that
white piece one two three and now you've
brought that blue red piece from where
where it used to be a problem over here
it's now up here on the top so we we
sort of kick it up to the top and that
works so okay now let's do it now it's a
blue red piece the blue Finds Its Center
it's got a red neighbor with red eye
slap
twist the top we do one two three fix it
with the other hand one two three all
right almost done uh let's look on the
rim I've got one more to go here's my
here's a blue blue orange we're lucky
the blue is already found its Center
I'll slap with the left
like that
and now with the left hand I do the one
two three move
one two three and then I'm going to fix
that white with my right hand firstly
orange Finds Its Center
and then we fix the white one two three
and now we've completed the middle layer
the middle layer is probably the longest
step in the process because you've got
four cubes to fix great we're halfway
through our algorithm and we have two
thirds of the Cube completed before we
do step five we learned we need to learn
some simple notation there are six faces
on the cube and according to Convention
they are labeled front
and back
right and left
up
and down
we abbreviate these with their first
letters f
b r l u and D
note that in our algorithm the up face
will always be yellow
and the down face will always be white
okay I don't know about the others but
but up face will always be yellow when
we use a letter to represent a move it
means to imagine that you're looking at
that face then twist that face in the
clockwise direction for example the U
Move If I'm looking at the up face
then uh then a U Move would look like
this I'm twisting it clockwise right the
r move would be to look at the right
face and twist it
clockwise I'll do it slowly just like
that that's an R move okay uh to move
counterclockwise we use the prime symbol
for example to move the move R Prime
would undo the last R move by turning
the right face counterclockwise so
here's the move R Prime
like so notice that the r move moves the
right face away from you but the L move
moves the left face
towards you that can be a little
confusing right now the L move would
look like um I'm going to look here and
turn clockwise that's an L move there's
L Prime right or from here there's L
Prime from here here's r
and going back is R Prime
okay it sounds confusing but as a
practical matter we mainly perform r
you
and F moves
and their reverses
by the way mathematicians might prefer
to say things like R inverse and write
it this way but R Prime is much easier
to say and write right
okay so we're ready for step five which
I call the fur Earth step see how it's
written where our goal will be to create
a yellow cross on the top face
and the bet is that we don't have a
yellow cross I got a yellow line here
that's kind of nice but I want a whole
yellow cross and the best time to
perform this step is at nine o'clock now
what do I mean by that if you're lucky
you'll have on the top face two yellow
Edge pieces that are touching diagonally
along with of course the you know and
also touching the center so you would
that those you'd have three yellows that
form nine o'clock if you have that
you're in good shape if you you'll only
have to do this next step once if you
don't have it like here we're going to
have to do this Step at least twice okay
so now here's the fur Earth step okay so
the fur f u r is performed clockwise and
the Earth step is done counterclockwise
okay here we go
um fur f
U
r
U Prime
R Prime
F Prime
and notice we now have nine o'clock you
might have to do that for earth move
twice to get nine o'clock but once you
have nine o'clock you're ready to do it
you only have to do it one more time so
um if if the position looked like here
and it was three o'clock and make it
nine o'clock if the position looked like
here like 3 30 you know make it nine
o'clock okay so so these two yellows are
away from you and we do fur Earth one
more time all right here we go
f
U
r
U Prime R Prime
F Prime and we now have a yellow cross
okay congratulations you're done with
step five
if you want to practice this move a few
more times go right ahead you can do fur
Earth all you'd like and unless you make
a mistake you won't disturb the bottom
two layers if you do make a mistake and
create a mess well it's a good time to
practice steps one to five anyway
are you ready for step six we're going
to make we're going to make the top
entirely yellow
and best of all you already know how to
do it we just use the fun move that I
taught you at the end of step three
remember how it went out twist in twist
out twist twist in now before you do the
move you look at the top face here and
count the number of yellow Corners that
are on the very top okay how many do I
have here I have two oh too bad the best
number to have is one if you're lucky
you'll only have one yellow Corner okay
but if you have zero or two yellow
Corners then you're gonna have to do
this for Earth step
um I mean you're gonna have to do this
the fun move step a few times okay here
now by the way it's impossible to have
three exactly three yellow Corners
that's actually a consequence of those
even positions that we talked about
earlier but I digress okay so here I
have two now when you have two on the
top what you do is you rotate your Cube
until you find a yellow on the on the
the face the the uh the front face here
in the upper left corner so I have a
yellow here do I have it anywhere else
no no no okay so the only way I can
Orient this is with the with the yellow
in the upper left corner of the front
face okay here I am looking at it and
now we do the fun move
um at least once maybe twice here we go
I'm gonna go out twist in twist out
twist twist in oh lucky me I now have
one yellow corner okay if I had two
yellow Corners I'd Orient my Cube until
I found a yellow over here but with one
yellow corner it's it's a it's nicer you
just Orient the cube until the one
yellow the one yellow uh
uh one yellow sticker here is in the
bottom left corner okay so now I'm
looking here on the up face my yellow
corner is here and I'm going to do this
fun move at least once maybe twice I can
tell from here I'm going to need to do
it twice all right so we'll do it once
out twist in twist out twist twist in
still one yellow Corner once you only
have one you're in good shape you're
always going to have one or you'll be
done I Orient my Cube so that one yellow
corner is over here in the bottom left
I'll do fun move one more time and we'll
be done with the step out twist in twist
out twist twist in oh it's looking
magical isn't it all right so now the
top face is entirely done
we are so close to being done here we
are at step seven at the end of this
step all of the all of the top corners
will be perfect
first thing you do is you look around
the top rim and see if any of the sides
have matching Corner colors okay so
usually I do but I think this time I
don't that's okay red orange green blue
orange red and blue green well in this
situation doesn't matter how you Orient
the cube and so let's do the r Prime f
move now I find that this is probably
the hardest step to learn it's only nine
twists but it's worth memorizing the
Mantra so repeat after me
R Prime f r Prime B2
r f Prime R Prime b 2 R2
I'll say it again
R Prime f are prime B2 r f Prime R Prime
b 2 R2 and that's it the B2 means to
twist the back side twice okay like
twice like that it doesn't matter
whether you twist it clockwise or
counterclockwise it has the same effect
if I do B2 again I'm back to where I was
all right and R2 means to do the the r
move twice like one two I'll do it again
R2 1 2. all right so let's do this step
very slowly of all the steps this was
the one that I found myself messing up
the most all right and if you mess up
you'll have to start all over again but
think of it as good practice of the
earlier steps okay since I don't have
any matching uh Corners it doesn't
matter how I Orient it as long as the
yellow side is on top here we do here we
go I'll do it slowly
R Prime
f
R Prime
B2
r
F Prime
R Prime
B2
R2
now when we have finished this step we
now have at least one side that has
matching Corner Colors Let's see that's
red orange green red blue blue that's
good orange green so take the blue blue
and that should be on your back I like
to match it up with the actual blue side
I just think it looks nicer okay so here
I've got the blue blue
on the back and and now we do R Prime f
one more time and once we do it
everything all those Corners are going
to be perfect all right one more time
R Prime f
R Prime
B2
r
F Prime
R Prime
B2
R2
and now uh what we'll Orient just so
that our matching colors are matching
and look at that isn't that pretty
you've got red green orange and blue
okay
ready for step eight the final step of
solving the Rubik's Cube
now at this point everything should be
in its proper position and orientation
except for three or four Edge pieces on
the top
now if you only have three Edge pieces
out of position then you'll have one
completely pristine side and just like
with step seven you'll want that to be
on the back side now let me see do I
have any uh no this is out of position
this is out of position I've got four
out of position so just like with step
seven it doesn't matter how I Orient the
cube this time but we're gonna have to
do this furl move a couple of times I
call this the furl step with an
exaggerated F because the way the move
is spelled out I'll display it for you
now but I remember it with a simple
mnemonic
so here it is look at it and here's my
mnemonic as I think about furl I start
with f f u
okay I'm gonna I'll do that for you here
f
f
U
and then I bring both sides down all
right that's the r Prime L both sides
down
then I dial around that's FF
then I bring both sides up that's r l
Prime and then that's enough of uff so I
do up f f
okay now you'll notice we have a
pristine side okay so if you didn't have
a pristine side before you will now all
right we're going to do this one more
time maybe twice we do furl one more
time I'll say my words this time instead
of the notation all right so furl so I
do f f u then
both sides down
dial around
both sides up
and that's enough
and look at that we have solved the
Rubik's Cube